you imagine that all of this is a
relatively surreal moment
given the fact that he had been watching
from home for so long and
of course has his dad there
on the sideline able to watch his son do
what he loves and this is a basketball
affair in kyrie irving's life his dad
rhetoric a star at boston university
[Applause]
[Music]
kyrie was born in melbourne
australia when frederick was playing
professionally
[Music]
then settled down in west orange new
jersey a nets fan as a kid growing up
dreaming
of one day
getting to this
moment
michael grady standing by with
kyrie
kyrie you said you could barely sleep
the night before your first practice
with your teammates last week with your
dad sitting there courtside what were
your emotions tonight as you played your
first game with your teammates since
it was amazing look at this look at
stephanie going man
[Applause]
yes sir baby yes sir appreciate you god
oh man it felt amazing man i don't want
to take this for granted
um you know a long time coming it's been
been months man so just to get back here
uh in indiana you know play against a
good pacers team i know they're missing
a few players but uh we just want to
come out with a resilient attitude and
just do the right things on both ends of
the floor sure you could tell how much
this means to kyrie irving to be back to
be in the arena
of putting his skills on display and
doing what he loves
including
his jersey for his dad
he carries that name irving